Christian du hältst die Schuldenbremse
gar nicht ein du arbeitest mit
Schattenhaushalten das ist exakt
dasselbe wie Schulden du willst nur das
wortchulden nicht sagen aus Trotz oder
Ideologie keine Ahnung mittlerweile tust
du so als wä die Schuldenbremse ein ein
lebendiges Wesen das du beschützen musst
unsere Schuldenbremse ist intelligent
sie nimmt die konjunkturelle Entwicklung
wahr oh Gott unsere Schuldenbremse ist
intelligent geworden wir müssen sie
töten bevor sie Eier
die Transformation der deutschen
Wirtschaft geht nicht ohne große
Investition und wenn du das als
Finanzminister nicht kapierst dann
müsstest du ein ehrliches
Personalgespräch mit dir selber führen
und dir sagen dein Arbeitsplatz fällt
weg geh nach Hause wir brauchen dich
nicht mehr